MARK: Welcome, my
name is Mark.
And I'm here with the
Authors@Google program.
And today we're here to welcome
Michael Clark, who is
an adventure photographer,
surfer, skier, climber.
I don't know if I've missed
any, but you can certainly
fill us in on that.
And he was here about two
years ago to tell us in
general about how he shoots
and sort of the
stories that he tells.
And in the intervening time,
he's been doing a lot of
shooting for big name clients
out in the field, all
different kinds of adventure
and sports photography.
And he's here today to go a
little bit more in-depth on
some of those stories behind the
image, and to get a little
bit more grungy about how they
come about, how you actually
construct them, and how you
actually get them to look like
they do when you actually see
them in print, online, or
wherever you encounter them.
So with that, I'd like to bring
up Michael to tell us
some of those stories.
Michael.
[APPLAUSE]
MICHAEL CLARK: All right.
Thanks for having
me out, guys.
Thanks, Mark.
Thanks for having me back.
It's a pleasure to be here.
And like Mark said, I'm an
adventure sports photographer.
I live in Santa Fe,
New Mexico.
I've been working for 16 years,
shooting for pretty
much any and every outdoor
client out there.
Magazines like "Outside,"
"Men's Journal," "Sports
Illustrated," some stuff with
"National Geographic." Clients
like Red Bull, Apple,
Adobe, Nike.
I work with Nikon a lot.
I'm a Nikon shooter--
not to create a controversy.
And over the last 16 years in
the adventure sports world,
I've had tons of adventures.
So the reason I'm out here is
this book that I just wrote
and finished earlier this year
that some of you have gotten.
And we'll give away a free copy
of this after the show.
The book is "Exposed--
Inside the Life and Images of
a Pro Photographer." And my
last book was "Adventure Sports
Photography," kind of a
how-to for all the
different sports.
This one's more of a revealing
book about what is the life of
a pro photographer like?
And I'll talk about that during
the presentation.
And it also talks about the
stories behind 16 of my
best-known images,
which are fairly
adventurous, the stories.
And then it talks about how I
set those images up, how they
were shot, the gear used, and
then how the images were
processed, so that I could give
the reader a full view of
how does this work from
beginning to end?
How did he get into position?
How did he meet these people
that are really famous
athletes in the outdoor world?
And who was I working for,
and all that jazz.
So we'll talk about that.
Just to give you a little
idea of the
book, there's the cover.
There's chapters.
This is "Keeping the Fire
Stoked." It's one of the
chapters that talks
about four images.
I'll keep going here.
And this just shows you
some of the chapters.
There's even little lighting
diagrams to show you how I had
the strobes set up.
I think pretty much every
picture in the book that has
strobes used in it of these 16,
there's a little lighting
diagram that shows you how the
lights were set up, and
describes in detail which lights
I had, which light
modifiers were on the lights,
and all the details.
The other thing I didn't
say is that in
the back of the book--
in the book, it talks about how
the images were processed.
But in the back of the book,
there's this DVD where you can
sit there and watch me
work up each of those
16 images as well.
And some of them took four,
five, six hours to work up.
So you don't see all
that, obviously.
But there's like a five or
six-minute min piece and I'll
do a little bit of what I did
to work it up, and then show
you the finished product
on the DVD.
Then these little vignettes--
some of these chapters talk
about what it was like out in
the field, being a pro.
This was in Tahiti, and I'll
talk about this whole series
of images I produced
in Tahiti.
Going to Tahiti to
shoot for 10 days
sounds pretty glamorous.
But reality was quite
a bit different.
So in terms of the job, I
have an office at home.
I'll talk about percentages
and where I
spend most my time.
It's probably 10% to 15% of my
time is spent shooting, having
these adventures.
This is a shot a buddy of
mine took in Patagonia.
I was covering an expedition
race down there.
It's like an adventure race,
where there are sea kayaking,
mountain biking, climbing,
and trekking.
One of most remote places
in the world.
We're probably 600 miles
from the nearest
city at this point.
And it's just like a swampland
that you're walking through.
And I have my cameras around my
neck, because I don't want
them to get drenched.
Anyway, we were following
the racers through
this muck and mire.
Often it involves carrying a
bunch of really heavy packs.
Oh yeah, I have a
clicker, too.
I forgot about that.
I started out as a rock
climbing photographer.
When I first started out in
1995, I was living in France
and climbing two, three
months straight.
I was on a bicycle tour.
I'd quit my job in physics.
I studied physics at the
University of Texas in Austin
and worked for a year.
Then I started rock climbing.
And rock climbing's one of those
sports like surfing or
mountain biking.
You just get obsessed.
And I got obsessed.
And I couldn't stay in the lab
doing physics anymore.
I was working with grad
students, working like 14
hours a day.
And I just quit.
And I just took off, sponsored
by Visa and MasterCard, and
went climbing in South America,
Alaska, Mexico,
Europe, Thailand.
And so after two years, I
decided, you know, well, my
images look about as good
as those images in
the climbing magazines.
I think I can make
a go of this.
And I just went for it.
And after about three and a
half years, I had enough
clients built up that
I could go for it.
It was still sketchy
for a few years.
But I made it.
16 years later, here I am.
So this just gives you an idea,
in this picture, of what
it takes to shoot climbing.
I'm not that far off
the ground here.
But I just had a friend shoot
this so that people can see
what it looks like when you're
shooting from above.
I'm pulled up the rope, so
there's no rope down here, to
get in the picture.
And it's a fairly difficult
climb, if you're a climber.
But it's not crazy.
Here's a much higher off
the ground shot.
Same technique used
to get this.
It took us all afternoon to get
up here, probably four,
four and a half hours, because
we're 600 feet off the ground.
Whoops, let me go back.
This is Devil's Tower in
Wyoming, if any of you guys
have ever been there.
But pretty amazing position.
Sharp rock.
I've had some incidents with
sharp rocks and my ropes
getting cut, so I was pretty
sketched out in this place
because it was over a very
sharp rock when I
was hanging off here.
But I'll get into that here
a little bit later.
I'll just give you guys a little
bit of my work so you
can see what I do.
This is another shot of a
guy named Chris Sharma.
If any of you guys are climbers,
he's probably one of
the most famous climbers
in the world.
And this is a new sport called
deepwater soloing.
We're in Majorca, Spain, off the
coast of Spain, just south
of Marseilles.
And he is 70 feet off the
water with no rope.
So if he falls off from there,
he's going to hit the water.
It's a 100-foot climb.
It's 514.
At that time, it was one of
the hardest climbs in the
world, and this is the biggest
hold on the climb.
He hung on that hold for
20 minutes, twice.
So he'd climb in from the side,
go to this hold, and
then he'd climb out.
And then we'd do
it over again.
It was at dawn.
So the base of this route,
which you can't see, goes
underneath this roof.
And there's a 60-foot horizontal
roof, literally
here back to the door, that he
has to climb out to even get
to this position.
And the hardest move is the one
off that hold to the next
hold, which is like
six feet away.
He has to jump in this
dynamic move.
So some pretty exciting stuff.
I'm also an avid ice climber.
I mean, I shoot pretty much all
facets of ice climbing, as
you've seen.
I started shooting mountain
biking after like four or five
years of just shooting
rock climbing.
I realized I was going to be
really poor if I just kept
shooting rock climbing.
So I branched out into a bunch
of the other sports, and
mountain biking was one of the
first ones I started shooting.
This shot may look like
it's at sunset, and
the rocks all gold.
But this is a strobe.
It was a cloudy, overcast day,
and I just had a huge
Elinchrome Ranger strobe that
I blasted into this with an
orange gel on it to get
this end-of-day look.
This is actually an assignment
I shot for Adobe when they
came out with Lightroom, which
is where I met Mark, when he
was back at Adobe.
I shot some of the first
pictures for Lightroom.
And they wanted mountain biking
shots of people going
off huge cliffs and doing wild
stuff on mountain bikes to
download the software.
So we went out to Moab, and my
good buddy Ryan, who's one of
the best mountain bikers
out there, that I've
known for a long time.
This is a pretty classic jump
called a mushroom rock.
It's only about a 35,
40-foot drop.
He lands right in here, even
just out of frame.
But it's on rock, so if you mess
up, you're going to be in
the hospital for a long time.
So as you can start to see, one
of the coolest things of
my job is I get to see these
amazing feats of athleticism
happen in the outdoors.
This one's not quite
so dramatic.
But this is a shot
I shot for Nikon.
It's the first time I'd ever
shot JPEG-only for an
assignment, because it
was with one of their
point-and-shoots.
And so they asked me to go shoot
surfing and mounting
biking with their
point-and-shoots.
It was difficult,
let's just say.
I work with Red Bull
a lot as well.
This is Danny MacAskill.
You guys might know him,
because he's kind
of a YouTube superstar.
Started his career.
I'll tell you more about that
story, because there's a whole
set of images of
him, later on.
And I just started shooting
surfing five years ago.
When I wrote my last book on
adventure sports photography--
I live in New Mexico.
So obviously I'm not doing
a whole lot of
surfing these days.
We wanted to include a broad
variety of sports, and surfing
is obviously one of the big
adventure sports out there.
So I went to California and
started shooting surfing, and
then a fellow photographer
friend of mine, Andrew Eccles,
who's a very famous portrait
photographer from New York,
suggested I call this
guy Brian Bielmann.
So I called him up.
And he answered the phone,
we had a conversation.
I said, hey, can I interview
you for my book?
Because I don't really know
anything about surfing
photography, other than
just go stand on a
beach with a big lens.
And so he was gracious enough to
give me all the details for
my book of what it takes to be
in the water and what lenses
to use and how to set it
up and the housings,
and all that stuff.
And we hit it off.
And he's like, hey,
you need some more
pictures for your book.
Why don't you just flight out
here one of these days, and
we'll go shoot at Jaws.
And Jaws is like the mega-wave,
the 80-foot monster
off the north coast of Maui.
So I was like going crazy.
I was like, sure, I'll
do that right away.
Whenever the next wave comes
up, I'll hop on a
plane to get out there.
So Jaws didn't come up
for a little while.
But he called me back the next
week and said, Pipeline's
going to be up at 20
feet next week.
Or it wasn't next week, it
was a few days from then.
So I hopped on a plane, I
was there in 12 hours
and shot with him.
We hit it off, and we've been
close friends ever since.
And he's kind of been my entree
into the surfing world.
Because I'm not really competing
for his clients.
I'm shooting surfing for these
other companies like Nikon and
Apple and other companies that
he doesn't really shoot for,
since he's shooting for,
specifically, the surf industry.
But this just happens to be a
55, 60-foot wave in Waimea
Bay, the last Eddie Aikau.
If anybody here's a
surfer, they'll
probably remember this.
The biggest surfing
competition in
the history of surfing.
Amazing waves.
And I went with him to Tahiti
last year, just shooting for
this book and also for
another client.
And you shoot from
a boat there.
The waves weren't
nearly as big.
But it was pretty amazing
in terms of the
perspectives you could get.
I've also shot a fair bit
of whitewater kayaking.
Let's see what else
we got here.
This is another shot
from the race.
This is, again, in Patagonia in
southern Chile, hundreds of
miles from civilization.
And that's in summer, with
still a lot of snow.
A little bit of backpacking.
I also have some shots, some
articles for clients where
basically, they just want a
photographer who can do crazy
stuff that other photographers
probably wouldn't do.
So for this, it was for "Men's
Fitness Magazine." And they
had me hanging off the bottom
of this helicopter, flying
over the ocean, and all kinds
of crazy shots, which I'll
talk about that in more
detail as well.
And I'll talk about how this one
was shot as well, because
there was quite a few strobes
on this image.
So a little bit of yoga.
This was for Patagonia, a client
just down the way.
And living in New Mexico, I've
shot at the Balloon Fiesta a
few times, and I've gotten
a few decent images.
Little landscapes
here and there.
This was in the Waimea Bay,
shot at the same time that
60-foot wave was happening.
This was the day before.
So this is a little pie chart
that's in the book.
And there was a few of these
that were running around
before I made this one up.
But I just made this up to
give kind of the reality.
Because everybody has this
perception that, oh, your
job's so glamorous.
And I'm always flying
off to somewhere,
this or that or whatever.
So they have no sympathy.
Which is OK.
They don't need to have
any sympathy.
But it just gives you a much
better idea of how much time
goes into marketing, how much
time goes into working up the
images, networking and
accounting, all the other
little things we do
as freelancers.
Definitely would say that
freelancing, it's an
up-and-down job.
Some years, like the last three
years, I've been off the
charts busy, just flying from
here to there to there to
here, it seems, every
other week.
And that's exhausting.
Sometimes it slows down a little
bit more, so you're not
as busy and you need to start
doing some other stuff.
So anyway, I'm definitely
not creating
images 65% of the time.
Traveling to exotic locations,
every once in a while.
Tahiti might be the first
truly exotic location.
I don't know.
Patagonia's fairly exotic, but
not quite the way people would
think, because it's usually
like 45 to 55 degrees and
raining sideways.
So it's not very enjoyable,
necessarily.
I don't know that I've ever
partied like a rock star,
maybe not since college.
And even then.
Before I go on a shoot,
I think one of the big
differences, I find--
because I teach some
photo workshops--
between amateur photographers
and professional photographers
is the amount of preparation
they do before a shoot.
That's not to say that amateur
photographers aren't doing the
same amount of preparation.
Some of them are.
There's a ton of amateur
photographers out there
getting amazing images, as we
see on the internet every day.
But the average professional,
I mean, for myself, I have
what I call a shot list.
It's not always in a book or
not always handwritten.
Sometimes it's typed out.
Sometimes it's on my iPhone.
And I've talked with a client
or I've talked with whoever
I'm going to be shooting
in that area.
And I've seen what they can do
or what's going to happen, to
some degree.
And I can start creating ideas
and think in my head, what
kind of shots do I want?
And I'll have a list of
20 to 30 shots of
things I want to get.
I'm not going to get all them.
I almost never get
all of them.
It's just something to help
me plan out the image.
So say it's a shoot
in New Mexico.
I will sometimes go scout
the location.
If I can scout the location
at all, I'll do that.
And that definitely helps.
Because then I can be, like,
this is going to be the
perfect angle, and it has
to be here at sunrise.
And you can kind of plan out
your shot and figure out,
well, can I use my speed
lights for this?
Do I have to bring out the
big guns, a giant strobe?
It's going to weigh a couple
hundred pounds with all the
other gear associated
with that.
Will I need assistance?
That just kind of helps set
you up for success.
And I do everything
I possibly can--
checking the weather.
I can almost predict where
clouds are going to go, just
by looking on NOAA's website,
and figure out that stuff.
So is it going to be crappy
weather that day?
Should we come back
a different day?
If I'm shooting in the woods--
like say, I'm showing up in the
redwoods here, I wouldn't
want a sunny day, because then
you have these bright patches
of light coming through these
into this dark forests.
I would look for an overcast
day-- which probably wouldn't
be that difficult to find here,
some times of the year--
so that the light's a
little more even.
Stuff like that.
And then I do a few shoots.
This is actually probably the
most well-known athlete I've
ever shot for the mainstream.
This is Camilo Villegas.
He's one of the top 20
golfers in the world.
And it was shot for State Street
Global Advisors, which
is a financial firm.
I had 45 minutes to
set up for it.
And I shot 12 images in a
matter of 24 seconds.
The art director came over to me
and he whispered in my ear,
he said, you've got 10 shots.
Make them count.
And he was watching, because I
was tethered to the laptop.
He was watching every
image come in.
So there was like this
insane pressure.
They had the layout.
They had everything dialed in.
Our lighting was dialed in.
For that 45 minutes,
we had a stand-in.
So I wasn't worried about
the lighting.
But it was just like--
[SNAP].
They were shooting a $4 million
commercial the same
day they were doing this.
So I had seconds, literally, to
get the images before they
had to go off and keep shooting
the commercial.
So there's a bit of pressure
sometimes.
This is a different version
of that image.
And you can tell-- he does this
little spider pose to
kind of assess the greens.
Super cool guy.
He's probably the fittest
golfer I've ever seen.
He's basically doing like a
one-armed push-up there.
But you can see here
how that was shot.
So I'll just go back
to that image.
There's a light in
front of him.
So there's a light coming in
from kind of this angle, and
there's two lights behind him.
It was fairly windy that day,
but you can see there was
these clouds behind here.
There was a storm moving in.
The winds were starting
to pick up.
When we got to the location--
I couldn't scout it first,
because it's on this really
fancy green.
The Accenture Golf Tournament
happens there in Tucson.
It's some mega-tournament that
was happening that day, or
later that weekend.
And they wouldn't let us take
anything onto the greens.
So no lightstands, no
tripods, no nothing.
And so I was like, OK, what
are we going to do?
But well, I figured,
he's in this pose.
We just laid everything
on the ground.
Put soft boxes on the lights,
laid them on the ground.
Had different people come hold
them, because the wind was
blowing everything away.
Laid the laptop on the ground.
Put my jacket over it so the art
director could watch the
images as they came in.
And we figured it
out on the fly.
And the lighting diagram
is something like this.
Pretty simple set-up.
Just took a little time
to figure it out.
Here's another image,
just to talk about
some of these images.
This is the finished image.
This was actually shot
not in a studio.
He's a free diver.
This was taken in New Mexico.
There's a place called
Blue Hole.
And he had just dove to the
bottom of Blue Hole, which is
like 100 feet down, holding his
breath for, I don't know,
a couple minutes.
He works with the Cousteau
Society a lot, Nico Danan.
He's on the cover of the book.
Good guy.
So I told him after the
dive-- the location
was not super scenic.
And the water was frigid.
And I didn't have an underwater
housing with me
that day, so I told him, look,
I'm going to set up this
little studio over here.
Just get out of the water
and come straight over.
And so the studio was set up.
I just basically taped a white
backdrop in the entrance-way
to the men's bathroom.
So it was pretty hilarious.
It was a tiny little area.
I mean, in fact, the length
of the men's bathrooms is
probably not much longer than
the width of that image.
So it was a tiny little area.
And I shot this.
This is pretty much the
lighting diagram.
There wasn't all this
other stuff.
There were no stands
or anything.
It was just taped to the white
background of the wall.
There was a light behind him
that was shining onto the
background, to illuminate
the background so
it'd be pure white.
And then I had a shoot-through
umbrella on a strobe.
Basically it was right
above my head.
And literally, he was only
three feet away.
This was shot with a
17 to 35mm lens.
So he was only like three feet
away from me, really close.
And that's the shot that
came out of the camera.
Which I have to say, as
a pro, that sucks.
And that's not going to
win any awards at all.
So I knew this technique was
what I was going for.
It was a high-contrast
black-and-white technique.
So I knew when I was shooting
what I wanted
to do in the end.
So that's why I shot
it this way.
And I knew it was going to
become this high-contrast
black-and-white image that
looks like that.
So with a little bit of
post-processing, this is what
I did to it in Lightroom.
Basically, I converted it to a
high-contrast black-and-white.
I cranked the contrast
up a little bit,
crunched the blacks.
You can still see there's
like a few things.
I think this is a hot pixel
from my camera.
I can't remember what that is.
I cleaned up his face a little
bit in Photoshop.
And here you can see
the final image.
So there's some cleaning
up of the face.
I did a little stuff
down here.
Did a little fancy footwork with
the unsharp mask to give
it a little more crunchiness.
This is before the clarity
slider in Lightroom.
And this is what I came up with,
which is a pretty cool
portrait, I think, because it
catches a moment where he's
kind of in this weird
zone of just having
come out of the water.
And the funny thing is, I took
a bunch of portraits of three
or four different
guys that day.
And they all said I got them.
Which you know, in the
parlance of portrait
photography, people talk about,
oh, we got their soul,
or whatever.
That's total crap.
You can't get anybody's
soul on film.
It's just you can get a piece of
them, maybe, that they can
relate to, or they see a piece
of themselves in the image.
And that's what they were
saying, that we could get a
piece of them in the
image somehow.
Here's a rock climbing image.
And there was the lighting
diagram for this earlier.
This is a climber named
Timmy Fairfield.
This was shot probably an
hour and a half from my
house in Santa Fe.
And I had been to this location
a bunch of times
before, so I didn't
need to scout it.
We'd been talking about
this image for years.
So talk about preparation.
We had been thinking about this
image for a long time.
He has been, historically,
one of the best
climbers in the world.
He's an amazing climber.
This is a super hard route.
It was 98 degrees the day we
decided to do this in I think
it was August.
And I had to carry 200 pounds
of lighting gear
up into this cave.
I didn't have an assistant that
day, because we were just
trying to do it--
it was just a portfolio shoot.
I didn't have a client
for this image.
It was just something I went
out and wanted to do.
And he's sponsored by a whole
bunch of companies I've worked
for, so I thought, oh,
after the fact,
we'll sell this image.
No big deal.
So we got up in the cave.
We waited.
The whole idea was to get a
set-up with the lights and
everything and then
wait for dusk.
You know, that 15 minutes after
the sun went down and
the clouds are illuminated
in the
background is what we wanted.
And we got it.
Didn't take that long to
set up the strobes.
As you can see here, there's
just two strobes set up.
All the strobes that I have
are battery-powered.
These are older Dynalite ones.
And one of them had what's
called a spot grid on it.
And that focuses the light
to a certain area.
You see how that's carved out
up there and it goes black
really fast?
That's kind of showing
you where the
spot grid is hitting.
And this other one, I took the
spot grid off and just filled
in this area over here in
the cave that was dark.
The other thing you probably
wouldn't know is this is shot
with a fisheye.
Because there's no straight
lines in the cave.
The cave wasn't huge.
The cave was probably about the
size of this room, and the
opening probably not too much
bigger than floor-to-ceiling
over there.
But with the fisheye, I could
make it look more voluminous
than it actually is.
And here's Danny MacAskill.
I was talking to you
guys, he was the
backflip picture earlier.
Red Bull, one my first jobs for
Red Bull was with this guy
Danny MacAskill.
And he had just signed with Red
Bull like the day before.
His life turned over in
a matter of months.
Because he's from Scotland.
He was working in a bike
shop as a mechanic.
And he and his roommate decided
to make a video.
And this kid's been riding
since, I don't know, two or
three years old.
I don't know how long he'd
been riding a bike.
But he did this video where
they're riding along a spiked
fence and doing all these
crazy things.
You've probably seen it,
because everybody-- my
grandmother saw it and knew who
the guy was before I did
the assignment.
I was kind of blown away.
But basically, he got like the
second-highest number of
YouTube hits in two weeks,
at that point.
And next thing he knows,
he's on Oprah.
"The New York Times" is doing
articles with him.
He does a Volkswagen
commercial.
He's being asked to do movies.
His life changed overnight.
He's the nicest kid.
So it's pretty cool to see
how that worked for him.
In this example, we went on an
aircraft carrier in San Diego.
He was visiting San
Diego, because his
sister lived there.
And so Red Bull set up that we
could get on this aircraft
carrier by ourselves.
And you know, as soon as we got
on the aircraft carrier,
it's like a museum.
They wouldn't let
us do anything.
So we were just taking pictures
of him hopping like
little security ropes, which
for him is boring.
So he suggested, hey, can
I go up there and
stand on those boxes?
And the guy that was taking us
around was like, yeah, sure, I
don't think you can hurt
anything doing that.
So he goes up there, and he gets
on top of this box over
here and he pops a wheelie.
And he's told the guy and he's
told us earlier today, I'm
more comfortable on my bike than
I am on my own two feet.
There's an 80-foot
drop right here.
And the boxes are
like this wide.
So he's sitting,
pops a wheelie.
And the guy's standing
like right here.
And I'm not really shooting
too much, at this point,
because it's like, is he just
going to sit there?
I mean, what are
we going to do?
So then he hops from one box
to the other and then
hops off the box.
And the art director is standing
right next to me.
And she says, his t-shirt, we
can't see any branding,
because he's wearing a helmet.
And Red Bull's all about having
branding in their
images, as you saw with
the Red Bull Stratus
project here lately.
So she has a whole box full
of t-shirts and stuff.
She was like, we got to put a
t-shirt on him, so you can see
the Red Bull logo bigger.
So to get up to this place,
you've got to go in here and
go up there and do
this and do that.
So the guy had to come down to
help usher her up to there.
And as soon as he left, Danny
just started going nuts, just
like doing all these tail whips
and back-flips, and
going from box to box.
And that's when I just blasted
away and start
shooting this stuff.
You know, working this image up,
it looks exactly like this
in the camera.
So most of my images, I'd say,
they look like this, the way
I'm showing them to you
now in the camera.
There's just a few I'll show you
that took these huge leaps
and bounds in terms of how
the processing is done.
Later in the day, we
went to these.
These were over by the
airport in San Diego.
But we'd found the day before.
I spent a whole day with Danny
scouting, because he'd never
been to San Diego before.
This is just an example of how
scouting can help you out.
And we found these, because I
drove right by them when I
came into town.
I was like, wow,
those are cool.
I wonder if he could do a
back-flip off of them.
And there was literally cars--
it was like rush hour.
There were cars just packed
around this island, right in
front of the airport.
And I thought, there's
no way they're going
to let us do this.
We're going to have the
cops on us in seconds.
Anyway, we go out there.
He does this like five
times to feel it out.
He couldn't get it right
off the bat.
But after like five tries, he
could do it on command.
And so we had him do it.
I pulled back, shot
one like this.
And then I did a closer up.
At one point, there was a cop
that pulled up over there.
And I just put my camera own
and started walking away,
because I thought, that's it.
We're done.
And Danny did it
one more time.
And the cop was like,
yeah, man!
That's awesome!
So I was like, OK, let's
keep shooting.
[LAUGHTER]
MICHAEL CLARK: Earlier in the
day, we'd been kicked out of a
few places already.
I mean, there was some--
I think it was a retirement
home or something.
We had him jumping off
the top of this--
I don't have the picture
of that one--
the top of this little gazebo.
And somebody went ballistic and
called the cops on us, and
we had a huge drama.
But anyway the nature of the
beast with that kind of stuff.
One of the other Red Bull shoots
I did was this stuff
with the Red Bull Air Force.
And most of the base jumping--
does everyone know what base
jumping is?
Base jumping is where you leap
off of some fixed thing, like
a bridge or an antenna
span or a huge cliff.
This is in Utah.
And I promised those guys I
wouldn't tell people exactly
where it's at, because this is
one of the most dangerous base
jumps in North America.
It's in very southern,
very remote Utah.
I'll just say that.
It's a 3,200-foot cliff.
And we had a helicopter.
It was a pretty big expense.
"ABC News," "Nightline" was
doing a piece on these guys
and how they deal with
danger and stuff.
And so it was a huge kind of
thing. they had like seven
guys from "Nightline" out
there filming this.
There were three jumpers.
If you've seen the last
"Transformers" movie, these
are the three guys that were in
"Transformers 3," jumping
through downtown Chicago.
Anyway, these guys are
incredibly talented.
They've done like
17,000 jumps.
It's not like they just walk
out there and put a suit on
and jump off a cliff.
So we get out there, and the
weird thing with this shoot is
I was going to be there
for three days.
We were supposed to
shoot at dawn.
It was howling like 70 miles an
hour wind, all night, all
day the day before.
And the morning we woke
up, it was like 60
mile an hour winds.
This is not going to happen.
You're not jumping off a cliff
in 60 mile an hour winds.
So somehow the winds died down
to like five miles an hour at
10 o'clock.
So we thought, let's
go for it.
The helicopter came up
from Salt Lake City.
And we got up to the
top of the cliff.
And they got three jumps in
each, which is pretty amazing.
Then the wind started up
a couple hours later.
The guys from ABC requested that
they use smoke canisters
so they could actually
see them.
There was one ABC film
cameraman on top.
And there were a couple
lying down at the
bottom, 3,000 feet away.
So you can imagine, 3,000
feet away, it's a
freaking dot in the sky.
You can't see anything.
And for me, there was really no
shot from the ground that
was going to be that exciting,
as a still photographer.
So I elected to go up to
the top with them.
They had another cameraman
shooting from a helicopter.
But it was tough, because these
guys are moving so fast
after they fall off the cliff.
They're going like 120 miles
an hour within a second.
So anyway, what I did
is, there's all
these little bushes.
And being a climber, that's why
I went up top, because I
thought I could rappel off the
top of the cliff and kind of
be underneath them
as they come over
the edge of the cliff.
So we get up there.
There's not a single
rock in sight.
There's nothing to tie off
to, except for these like
two-foot-tall bushes.
And they're like this thick.
So what did I do?
I tied off like 15 of them.
And I slowly down-climbed over
the edge of the cliff down to
a little ledge, never weighting
the rope fully.
Because I was like, that's not
going to hold anything.
Anyway, it was a little
exciting, in that respect.
And they jumped with these
canisters, which the bad thing
about these canisters were,
they'd have to pull it before
they jumped.
And there's like this
little platform.
It's like standing on the
edge of this table on
a 3,200 foot cliff.
And they've got to kind of
compose themselves after they
pull the cork before
they jump.
And so they're just basically
jumping out of a cloud.
So you can't even really tell
what's going on in the image.
They each went individually,
too, because it
was a little windy.
So it wasn't one of those jumps
where they could all
three go at the same time.
And hence, I didn't
mount any remote
cameras because of that.
Let me back up for a second.
The other fact is-- you can't
see it in this image,
necessarily.
Like 1,000 feet down, basically,
the first thing
they do is they go to the edge,
they drop a rock, and
count how many seconds
it takes for the
rock to hit the ground.
Well, this one, in five seconds,
hit a ledge that was
60 feet wide, flat,
1,000 feet down.
So they're like, we've got to
start flying away from the
wall within five seconds.
Otherwise we're going
to hit that ledge at
100 miles an hour.
And then right after they
get away from the
wall, it's the canyon--
you'll see from the
next picture.
So the ledge is hard to see.
It's down here.
And the canyon looks really
wide at this point.
This is a fisheye shot.
They had to make a 90-degree
left-hand turn right after
they get away from the ledge
so they don't fly into the
other side of the canyon.
So super technical drop, which
is why they told me not to
tell anybody the location.
They only did it three times,
because it was so technical.
They said it was like a triple
black diamond ski jump.
Anyway, so the second time
around, after begging them not
to use the smoke canisters,
they didn't
use the smoke canisters.
And that's when I
got this shot.
And to improve my odds of
getting shots-- because
literally for this assignment,
I had nine
seconds to get the images.
Because after second,
they're gone.
It's over.
And they each went three
times, so three
times three, nine.
So I had two remote cameras
set up on either side.
And then I would shoot with
one camera and had a
PocketWizard radio transmitter
triggering those other cameras.
So at least I would get three
angles of view on each jump.
And this is the one I
got with my camera.
And that seemed to be the
best shot of the day.
But pretty amazing, going
out these guys.
I was trying to follow them with
a 7200 as they went down
the cliff line.
I only got like 1 out of 12
shots where the guy was even
in the frame, because they
were moving so fast.
And that just kind of shows
you the trajectory.
This is the same guy
as he goes down.
So what ended up happening,
I think they got
90 seconds of air.
And they landed somewhere
right out
there on this riverbed.
So you can see that it's crazy
with these guys are doing.
It's amazing.
I mean, people ask me, like
all these extreme
sports that I do.
This is the only sport I've
photographed that I would ever
call extreme.
All the other adventure sports
seem pretty doable.
This one, as a climber,
I wanted to jump
off that cliff bad.
I really thought, man,
this is so cool.
But you know, I'd have to spend
the next three, four
years of my life dedicated to
that sport to do it safely.
And this is a shot of one of the
guys, Miles Daisher, being
interviewed.
Super passionate guy.
Interesting thing, these
guys are all married.
One of them has kids.
All their wives were base
jumpers or had done
parachuting at one point.
So they understood the game.
And they were basically asking
them all these questions
about, well, how do you
guys deal with risk?
Do you talk about this with
your wives and stuff?
There's been a few of their
friends die in the last few
years at Red Bull as well.
So it's dicey.
But you know, these guys have
the experience to make it
safe, or at least deal
with the risks.
So on to surfing.
As I said earlier, I met Brian
Bielmann through my book, a
surf photographer.
He's been shooting surfing
for 25 years.
Inside the surf world, they
call him the godfather of
surfing photography.
Anybody and everybody he's
been on trips with.
He was close friends with
Andy Irons, who died a
couple years ago.
This shot is a shot I got one of
the first times I went out
to Hawaii and shot
at Pipeline.
And I have to say, Pipeline,
it's amazing, this wave.
And it's not amazing that it's
so famous, because it's such a
perfect wave.
It's really close
to the beach.
This was shot at like
9 o'clock at night.
It was practically dark.
But I just used a really
long shutter speed.
And I shot maybe 200, 300 images
to get this one, where
there's something just a
little bit sharp there.
Another shot at Pipeline.
This was during the Pipeline
Masters, or Pipe Masters
competition.
Yet another shot at Pipeline.
And my second trip out to the
North Shore of Oahu, I got
really lucky.
Because I had scheduled this
trip like a month or a month
and a half in advance.
So being that far in advance,
I had no clue if
there would be waves.
I just thought, you know what?
I need more surf pictures.
I'm going to go out there, stay
for two weeks, and see
what happens.
And this was the day before.
When I got there, I
got off the plane.
As I was driving to Brian's
house on the North Shore, like
an hour away, there were all
these warnings on the radio,
like, we've never seen a storm
of this size coming in.
Board up your home if you
live on the beaches.
We're evacuating all beachfront
property, because
we're expecting 60 to 80-foot
waves in Waimea Bay.
I was like, that sounds
horrific.
But it might be great for
surfing, so anyway.
[LAUGHTER]
MICHAEL CLARK: As it happened,
you know, like four or five
days later--
I can't remember exactly how
many days after I got there--
there started getting 20 to
30-foot waves in Waimea Bay.
And there's a contest
held every year.
It's the Quiksilver In Memory
of Eddie Aikau.
And Eddie Aikau was a lifeguard
on the North Shore,
a very famous lifeguard,
Hawaiian lifeguard, who would
swim out in basically
any size waves.
And he saved people in huge
waves that got caught in some
of these waves.
So the whole event is named
after him, sponsored by
Quiksilver--
hence the strange name,
if you're not
familiar with surfing.
And the deal with the Eddie
Aikau is the waves have to be
20-foot Hawaiian or bigger.
So the way they talk about
waves in Hawaii, which is
different than everywhere else
in the world, is that they
measure the back of the wave,
not the front of the wave.
So a 20-foot wave in Hawaiian
is 40 feet or more
front of the wave.
So like, here in California,
you would measure the waves
from the front, so you would
have maybe a six or seven-foot
wave on an average decent day.
For this event to even run, it
had to be 40-foot waves on the
wave faces.
So here's a good 30-footer
the day before the event.
And just to show you how
this one was worked up.
This is the final image.
I'm with a 900-millimeter lens,
maybe 3/4 of a mile away
from the wave, standing
on the shore.
Unless you're on a jet ski or
something out there, there's
not really any way
to get out there.
You can swim out, but once the
waves start getting this big,
it gets a little exciting.
So anyway, this giant wave.
There's a ton of salt spray
between me and that.
So this is how the image
came out of the camera.
Again, nothing to write
home about.
But I knew this was going to
happen, because there was just
so much water vapor between
me and the wave.
So in Lightroom, this is how
I manipulate the image in
Lightroom, basically adjusting
the contrast sliders and kind
of bringing the contrast
and color saturation
back into the image.
And this is how it changed from
Lightroom to Photoshop.
So it's a very slight
difference from
Lightroom to Photoshop.
If you know Photoshop, it's
basically just a levels
adjustment and a little bit of
fine-tuning on the saturation
there to get that.
But coming from that, that's a
pretty amazing difference.
Apple ended up using this
image a few years ago to
promote their MacBooks, I
think, on their website.
So this is the actual day of
the Eddie Aikau event.
These guys-- this is a small
wave from that day.
This maybe only a 30--
or, I don't know.
That's probably a 40-footer.
It's hard to tell, because you
can't see the bottom of the
wave, because at this point, the
wave hasn't even formed,
just as he just took off,
the top of the wave.
And you can tell, he's not
touching anything except for
the spray at the
back of there.
He didn't hit the
wave until here.
So pretty much everybody that
was catching waves-- and they
weren't using jet
skis this day.
There's no jet skis allowed
in the competition.
So they were paddling into
these waves, which are
technically some of the biggest
waves ever paddled
into by human beings.
So he free-fell off the top of
the wave for 15 to 20 feet
before he even hit the water.
And at that point, the water was
pretty much vertical until
he got to the bottom
of the wave.
And this is a smaller wave
from earlier in the day.
So you kind of see, here's
a little bigger wave,
later in the day.
This is like a 55-foot, maybe.
It's hard to tell.
55 to 60, 50 to 60 range,
somewhere in there.
It's Sunny Garcia.
This is definitely one of the
biggest waves of the day.
They were all kind of in that
50 to 60-foot range, for the
biggest waves of the day.
But for paddling into a wave,
that's just monster size.
Anyway, this is also shot
from the shore.
Pretty much looked
just like this.
This was a little clearer than
the day before, so there
wasn't as much water vapor.
I think I was using a is 500
f/4 with a 1.5 on it.
So it was basically
a 750 millimeter
lens, and a motor drive.
This is a shot of Andy Irons.
And this is kind of
a weird shot.
The funny story with this--
we were sitting on one point
right in front of the wave
when I was shooting some
of those earlier shots.
And then at another part of
the day, I walked over to
completely the other
side of the wave.
And there was only me and one
other guy, shooting video with
a giant red camera.
So I was the only
guy over there.
And what would happen is, the
wave breaks about 3/4 of a
mile offshore, collapses,
then reforms, then
collapses, then reforms.
And that last wave is basically
a beach break.
And it's like 50 yards
off the beach.
And those are very rare, to
catch a barrel doing that.
So this is a picture of Andy
Irons catching that barrel
right on the beach.
He was one of only two guys
the whole day to catch a
barrel right on the beach.
I was the only guy to
get the shot, so.
When I was editing 3,000, 4,000
shots later that night,
I was zipping through them,
and my friend Brian was
looking over my shoulder.
And he saw this image.
And I'm like, that's horrible.
Look at all that
jumbled water.
It's not very aesthetically
pleasing.
Like, Mike, you don't
understand.
This doesn't happen!
This is Andy Irons on a beach
break wave in the Eddie Aikau.
So he pimped out this image,
and it got published
all over the place.
And because I'm not a surfer,
I didn't know that this was
like some iconic image.
I still look at it, and I'm
like, that's not very good
compared to, you know,
one of this.
But you know, that's just
not knowing this sport.
So last year.
While writing this book, I've
wanted to go to Tahiti for a
long time, and Brian told me,
Mike, if you want to get the
best surfing images you ever
going to get in your whole
life, go to Tahiti.
Because you can sit on this
wave break, Teahupo'o--
or Cheo-pu is how the
locals call it.
Breaks right off the shore,
it's like a mile off
the beach on a reef.
The reef is literally like a
few feet under the water.
And it's right in front
of the wave.
So if the wave's braking where
the wall is back there, 40
feet away, the reef's
right here.
So if you make a mistake,
you're going to
pay for it big time.
People have had their faces
ripped off there.
A lot of people have
died there.
"Teahupo'o" means "broken
skulls" in Tahitian.
So those are some Tahitian
kayakers.
Kayaking is a huge
sport in Tahiti.
When I got there, I was
basically writing the book
sitting on a beach.
You know, the beginning of the
trip was fairly glamorous,
because I was sitting on the
beach, writing the book,
whatever, doing nothing in
this tiny little fishing
village on the opposite side
of any tourist thing.
And you had to stay
with locals.
There was no hotels on this side
of the island, so it's
very difficult to stay over on
that side of the island.
But literally, the village
is named Teahupo'o too.
And the wave is basically
right here.
And you can see, it's
totally flat.
There was nothing happening
when I first got there.
So I was just shooting
pictures of whatever
the first few days.
And this is the wave.
The wave isn't very big in this
picture, even though you
can't tell it.
This is probably a seven
or eight-foot wave.
It just looked really cool
from that perspective.
And the deal was this wave is
that it's so far out to sea,
you're either on a jet ski, or
in a boat, or you're swimming.
Because you can't shoot
it from shore.
You can barely even see it from
shore, unless it's huge.
So you're going over the
shoulder of the wave every
time it's coming by.
And that's what was
happening here.
I was in a boat.
And here's just an idea.
You can see some of the
photographers swimming.
And this is a little bigger.
It's an overhead wave, maybe
8 to 12 feet tall,
decent-sized wave.
The trick with this wave,
though, is it
moves incredibly fast.
So even though it's not as big
as some of the bigger waves in
Hawaii, the back of the wave is
pretty much level with the
top of the wave.
So it sucks it off the reef
and just snaps down like a
shark's mouth on top
of the surfer.
So even catching the wave is
really difficult, because it
forces it up so fast.
So it's a very hard wave.
And there's not many people
surfing this wave, unless
they're pro surfers, when
it gets to this size.
Also, being a photographer in
the water is pretty sketchy
here, because remember, that
reef's just in front of you.
And if you get pushed
onto that reef, it's
going to be a bad day.
I saw a few photographers crack
their camera housings
and come back bleeding.
Here's a little bigger wave.
The bottom of the wave is still
like five feet below
where he's at right there.
This was another surfing
competition.
I shot these before the surfing
competition started.
This was shot from the boat.
And you can tell I'm above his
position, because we're
already up on the shoulder
of the wave looking
down into the wave.
The day before the competition,
they had the top--
I think it's 36 surfers
in the pro series.
They had what they called
a free surf.
It's the first time they'd
ever done it in Tahiti.
So basically all the
pro surfers could
come out and surf.
And it was a decent day.
It was probably 20-foot
waves on the face.
This is Kelly Slater.
He put on an exhibition.
It's like he barely
even touched his
surfboard that day.
Everybody was just sitting
there, like,
how did he do that?
He was just cruising
all over the place.
Another picture of Kelly
on Teahupo'o.
So you can see the back of the
wave just keeps going.
It doesn't like go down,
like you would
normally see on a wave.
There's an insane amount of
volume snapping over you.
So if you mess up, there's
huge consequences on this
wave, even though it's smaller
than your average wave.
Now getting back to
land-based stuff.
I did another shot for Red
Bull with paragliding.
And this guy--
oh, what's his name?
I can't remember.
He was training for the Transalp
Race in Europe.
And basically, we did the
shoot in Salt Lake City.
For this race, you have to hike
or fly from somewhere in
Austria all the way to southern
France, through the Alps.
So it's an insane race.
So he's super fit, and we
did this photo shoot
in Salt Lake City.
This is the first strobed
image of a paraglider, I
think, that's ever been done.
I'd never seen one before,
and we tried to do it.
So I'm standing on a ridge with
an assistant strobing him
in early morning light.
And you can tell the
background's blurred, because
I'm using a long shutter
speed to bleed it in.
This is another one.
Chris Santacroce is the other
paraglider we were shooting.
He's doing what's called
a wingover.
So he's flying over the
top of his wave.
Not recommended.
He's one of the few guys
in the world who
could even do it.
And we had all these problems,
just, you know, being a pro
again, it rained entirely
the first day.
So that's why I shot
this portrait.
We just shot portraits the
entire first day, because it
was just pouring outside.
Then the next day, we got lucky
with some light and lots
of clouds and stuff.
And then the third day, I got
to go up in a paraglider and
shoot from paraglider
to paraglider,
which was kind of fun.
I'm not sure the image
was as good as some
of the other ones.
And then we flew over some
of the mountains
above Salt Lake City.
So just to show you
some variety.
I think I'm running
out of time here.
So I'll go a little faster.
Here are some of the images
from this "Men's Fitness"
article with a helicopter
search and rescue team.
These guys are up in Santa
Rosa, the Henry One.
And this is one of their
guys hanging 100
feet off the bottom.
They basically pluck people out
of the ocean, pluck people
off cliffs.
So I positioned one of the
copilots on one of their
training runs on this little
cliff, and you know, inched
him out a little more than he
was probably comfortable with.
Then I hung off the
cliff below him as
they picked him up.
This is an interesting thing.
I'd just gotten the new
Nikon D3 and D700.
And it was like 9:30 at night.
There was basically
no light left.
So I thought, these things are
supposed to be great, these
high ISOs,
let's try it Out.
So I slapped my 7200 on there,
cranked it up to ISO 6400,
shot like 50 shots of
this helicopter
going across the ocean.
And I had a walkie-talkie so I
could kind of control where
they were going to
some degree.
And amazingly, I got a shot
that was in focus and not
completely blurred.
And this image, I think
there's two strobes, a
headlamp, and a speedlight.
I just saw this scene and they
were putting on their night
vision goggles.
And I thought, let's go ahead
and get something here.
And 20 minutes later,
I had it set up.
And the last little piece was
that I couldn't really get
light to his face.
It was hitting this
pilot's face.
So I just had him hold my
headlamp, which I pretty much
always have in my camera bag.
And that's what this arm is
doing, holding a headlamp in
front of the heads-up display
to finish off the lighting.
I think I'll zip through a
few other images here.
There's a good story
with this one.
This is when I was shooting
the Patagonian Expedition
Race, which is the adventure
race I was telling you guys
about earlier.
We ended up in the middle of
nowhere after hiking for four
days, raging seas.
This fisherman and his son
were in this little bay.
This is in the Magellan
Strait.
It's at the very southern tip
of South America in Chile.
And there were three of us--
myself, another photographer,
and a writer--
and then a Chilean guide
who was with us.
We were all about to
go hypothermic.
Because they had pulled us out
into this bay, said, we'll
pick you up in this boat, we'll
take you to the end of
the race to cover this other
part of the race.
Anyway, they never showed up,
but this boat was there, by
some miracle.
Because we're still 600
miles from anything.
And so we call over
to their boat.
They pick us up.
We end up spending 36 hours
with these guys.
And this is Angel, he's 54, and
his son Steve, who is 36.
Both of them look like
they're about 83.
They were very weathered
faces.
He spent 15 hours a day under
the ocean in a one-inch
wetsuit, which you can see,
cutting this stuff called
luga, in Spanish.
I think it's red algae
is what it was.
We never really figured out
exactly what it was--
off the bottom of the ocean,
breathing out of a garden
hose, no compressor.
They had a compressor
but I mean, no
regulator or anything.
Just a cut-off garden
hose, that was
his breathing apparatus.
So the second day, he went down
and got a king crab for
us for lunch.
We wanted to photograph
these guys working.
And they wanted lunch.
So we're like, yeah, king
crab sounds great.
So this is him hanging over
the boat, watching us
get the king crab.
All right.
Let me go on here, show
the other images.
And just so you can see
how I market myself.
Obviously the website's home
base to everything these days.
I also produce a newsletter,
which these are some of the
covers of the newsletter.
It's a PDF newsletter.
They're free on my website,
michaelclarkphoto.com, which
I'll show here at the end.
You can go download those.
Those include equipment reviews,
stories behind the
images, kind of what I've been
talking about, digital tips,
editorial--
a whole bunch of other stuff.
I started producing these 10
years ago as just like a
printed one-side, front-and-back
mailer to
remind my clients I
still existed so
they'd hire me for jobs.
And now it's exploded into its
own little mini-magazine.
It's between 20 and 30 pages
every time I do it.
It's quarterly.
And it goes out to about
6,000 people now.
So it's just a way for me to
stay in touch with my clients
and also all the subscribers
that sign up for it.
And if you send me an email,
I'll put you on the list, and
you'll get the newsletter
whenever I get around to
writing it, which is
usually quarterly.
Sometimes it's only three
times a year.
And This gives you an idea
of what's in it.
Like this is a little story
about that shot.
There's equipment reviews of
some the Nikon lenses.
There's an interview with
"National Geographic" photo
editor Sabine Meyer in
one of the issues.
This is my other book that I was
talking about earlier, the
"Adventure Photography" book.
And I also have a Digital
Workflow e-book that you can
purchase on my website if you're
needing some Digital
Workflow help.
And that's pretty much it.
Thank you for having me out.
[APPLAUSE]
MARK: Thank you, Michael.
That was a really good talk.
I consider shooting a birthday
party with five-year-olds
about as adventurous as
I get, so this is
very, very, very humbling.
I appreciate it.
So we do have a little bit
of time for Q&A if folks
want to come here.
I know you have your book that
you want to give away.
Not for free.
I think people are going to have
to work for it a little
bit, so maybe we'll work
that in as well.
But if you do have a question,
please come up to the mic.
AUDIENCE: So how many pictures
do you actually
do Photoshop work?
Or what percentage of pictures
you don't edit at all?
Like how much?
MICHAEL CLARK: It varies
with the shoot.
So like some of those
surfing images.
Surfing, every time a surfer's
on a wave, you just hold the
trigger down and you're blasting
at eight to ten
frames a second or more.
And so you could
have thousands.
I think the Tahiti trip, I had
12,000 images from 10 days of
shooting, which is the most I
had ever shot in 10 days.
Sometimes a portrait, I
might take 50 shots.
And I might only work
up one or two.
So it depends on the shoot.
With the Tahiti thing, I think
I worked up maybe 100.
So that trip to Tahiti, I only
worked up 100 images out of
12,000 or 11,000.
It's very small, like less than
1% probably, 1% to 2%.
It depends on how good
the shoot was.
Like that Danny MacAskill shoot,
I think I worked up a
few hundred out of a
couple thousand.
So that was a bigger percentage,
just because we
got more interesting images.
AUDIENCE: Hi, great talk.
What percentage of the time do
you think you use like prime
lenses, fixed focal
length lenses as
opposed to zoom lenses?
And have you, in the situations
that would warrant
more of a prime lens kind of
approach, have you ever
considered using different
cameras, such as rangefinder
cameras, like Leicas and
things like that?
Because personally, I've found
the optics to just be
ridiculous on a Leica,
compared to a Nikon.
MICHAEL CLARK: Back in the film
days, I used to have a
Hasselblad set-up, which I had
all fixed lenses on that.
And I'd use that a fair bit,
sometimes even for action.
For my photography now, like
my fisheye is a fixed.
I've got an 85 fixed.
I've got some tilt-shift
fixed.
Most of the stuff's shot with
zooms, just because it allows
me more freedom and to carry
less gear, which is sometimes
a really big deal.
Even the telephoto stuff,
I have a 200 to 400.
So I have a balance.
But my zooms are my mainstays
for a lot of this stuff.
The new Nikons are
pretty amazing.
I mean, they're not Leica
quality lenses, but they're
not far off, from
what I've found.
I don't know.
And most of my clients demand
digital, so shooting film is
kind of a nightmare, because
then you have to scan the film
and that takes forever.
AUDIENCE: But I mean, Leica
has had two generations of
digital cameras.
And they're coming
onto their third.
MICHAEL CLARK: And they're
great, for sure.
But for action photography, they
don't have auto-focus.
They're not really
designed-- for
mountaineering, they're awesome.
So it just depends on
the application.
So anyway, thank you guys.
[APPLAUSE]